there's an african-american so 19th
century which M is so great it says when
it looked like the Sun will not shine
anymore God put a rainbow in the clouds
Matt and I've had so many rainbows in my
crown
I had a lot of clouds but I have had so
many rainbows and one of the things I do
when I step up on a stage when I stand
up to translate when I go to teach my
classes when I go to direct a movie I
bring everyone who has ever been kind to
me with me black white asian
spanish-speaking Native American gay
straight everybody has to come with me
I'm doing a mistake come with me I need
you now so I don't ever feel I have no
help and the thing to do it seems to me
is to prepare yourself so that you can
be a rainbow in somebody else's class
somebody who may not look like you may
not call God the same name you call God
if they call got it off and may not eat
the same dishes prepared the way you do
may not dance your dances or speak your
language but be a blessing to somebody
when I was seven and a half I was raped
the rapist was a person well known to my
family I was hospitalized the rapist was
let out of jail and was found dead that
night I thought I had caused the man's
death because I had spoken his name
that was magic so I stopped talking for
five years now to show you again how out
of evil there can come good in those
five years I read every book in the
black school library I read all the
books I could get from the white school
library I was saved in that mutinous
when I decided to speak I had a lot to
say and many ways in which to say what I
had to say I listened to the black
minister and listen to the melody of the
preachers and I could tell when they
would start up from that kind of thing
when we know they mean
take our soul straight to heaven I
understood it so out of this IVA rape on
the body of a young person more often
than not introduces cynicism and there
is nothing quite so tragic as a young
senate because it means the person has
gone from knowing nothing to believing
nothing in my case I was saved in that
mutinous I was saved and I was able to
draw from human thought human
disappointments and tryouts enough to
triumph myself you just watched two
amazing clips from Maya Angelou take the
next three minutes to sit quietly and
think about how you can apply them to
your business and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]